>> Tucker: HARVARD PROFESSOR
OF LAW ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS
ONE OF THE MOST
DISTINGUISHED AND CERTAINLY
ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
LIBERALS IN THIS COUNTRY.
INCREASINGLY HE DOESN'T HAVE
MUCH HOME LEFT ON THE LEFT
BECAUSE HE REFUSES TO
PARTICIPATE IN DOG THAT THE
PARTICULAR ATTACKS ON THE
PRESIDENT.
DERSHOWITZ HAS SHARP SOLID
CRITICIZED THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
HE SAYS JUSTIFYING ATTACKS
ON CIVIL LIBERTIES THAT ALL
OF US.
FOR SAYING THAT HE SAYS HIS
LIBERAL FRIENDS DON'T INVITE
HIM TO DINNER PARTIES
ANYMORE AND SOME BARK AT
HIM.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ JOINS
US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TAKEN
UNPOPULAR, REALLY UNPOPULAR
POSITIONS, SOME THAT I
DISAGREE WITH OVER THE
YEARS.
AND YOU HAVEN'T HAD THIS
PROBLEM.
>> NO.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE?
>> WELL, IT'S TRUMP.
TRUMP CHANGES EVERYTHING.
>> JUST YESTERDAY ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD THERE WAS
A DINNER PARTY.
MY WIFE AND I WAS NOT
INVITED.
APPARENTLY I WAS THE SUBJECT
OF THE CONVERSATION.
PEOPLE ASKING WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO DERSHOWITZ?
WHY HAS HE TURNED TO THE
RIGHT?
AND I WISH I HAD BEEN THERE
BECAUSE I YOU WOULD HAVE
POINTED MY FINGER AT MY
LIBERAL FRIENDS AND SAID
IT'S ALL YOUR FAULT.
IF HAD YOU WORKED THIS HARD
FOR THE ELECTION OF HILLARY
CLINTON AS I DID AND IF SHE
HAD BEEN ELECTED AND THEY
WERE TRYING TO IMPEACH OR
CHARGE HER, I WOULD BE
SAYING EXACTLY THE SAME
THINGS IN DEFENSE OF HER
RIGHTS.
AS I DID IN THE DEFENSE OF
THE RIGHTS OF BILL CLINTON
AND ALSO IN DEFENSE OF THE
RIGHTS OF RICHARD NIXON
GOING BACK TO THE 1970S.
I HAVE NOT CHANGED.
THEY HAVE.
>> Tucker: JUST AS A
REFERENCE POINT, YOU WERE
INVOLVED IN THE DEFENSE FOR
A LITTLE WHILE ANYWAY OF
O.J. SIMPSON ACCUSED OF
KILLING TO TWO PEOPLE WITH A
KNIFE.
WHEN YOU WENT TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD DURING THOSE YEARS
IN 1995 AND 1996, DID PEOPLE
ATTACK YOU AT DINNER PARTIES
FOR THAT.
>> A LITTLE BIT.
NOT AS MUCH AS THIS.
NEVER BEEN LIKE THIS.
THIS TIME IT INCLUDES SOME
OF MY RELATIVES.
AS I SAID THE ONLY THING
THAT HURTS ME IS THAT UP
UNTIL NOW PEOPLE WHO ARE MY
RELATIVES WOULD TELL ME OH,
PEOPLE COME OVER TO YOU AND
SAID YOU ARE RELATED TO ALAN
DERSHOWITZ, WOW NOW THEY
DERSHOWITZ HOW CAN YOU
JUSTIFY WHAT HE HAS BEEN
SAYING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP?
SO IT EFFECTS MY RELATIVES.
THAT HURTS ME.
I HAVE A THICK SKIN.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
YEARS.
I HAVE DEVELOPED THE
THICKEST SKIN IMAGINABLE.
BY THE WAY, A LOT OF THE
TWEETS THAT I GET HUNDREDS
OF TWEETS AND MESSAGES A LOT
OF THEM, NOT ONLY FOCUS ON
WHAT I HAVE BEEN SAYING
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF DONALD TRUMP, BUT
THEY RELATED TO ME BEING
PRO-ISRAEL AND JEWISH AND
MAKING ANTI-SEMITIC THING
OUT OF IT AS WELL.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
NOT ONLY SOME -- TOO MUCH
ANTISEMITISM ON THE RIGHT,
THERE IS QUITE A BIT ON IT
ON THE ANTI-TRUMP AS WELL.
>> Tucker: I HAVE NOTICED
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN AT THIS,
I WOULDN'T WANT TO GUESS
HALF A CENTURY.
FOREFRONT OF THE CIVIL
LIBERTARIAN LEFT.
HAS THAT GROUP SHRUNK?
IS IT NOT JUST TRUMP BUT
MAYBE THE LEFT IS LESS
INTERESTED IN TRADITIONAL
CIVIL LIBERTIES THAN IT USED
TO BE?
>> SHRUNK, THERE ARE NO
CIVIL LIBERTARIANS LEFT ON
THE LEFT.
CERTAINLY NOT THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION.
THEY WERE THE ONES WHO SAID
THAT THE RAID ON COHEN'S
OFFICE TAKING HIS LAWYER
CLIENT FILES WAS A GOOD
THING.
NOT EVEN SUGGESTING WHAT I
SUGGESTED AND ULTIMATELY
ADOPTED BY THE JUDGE TO HAVE
A JUDICIAL MONITOR GOING
THROUGH.
ALL OF THESE EMAILS.
THE ACLU IS DEAD IN THE
WATER WHEN IT COMES TO
DEFENDING THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES OF PEOPLE WHO THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH.
AND THAT'S JUST AWFUL.
THERE ARE STILL SOME CIVIL
LIBERTARIANS LEFT.
BUT YOU CAN COUNT THEM ON
ONE HAND.
EVERYBODY HAS TO PASS THE
SHOE ON THE OTHER FOOT TEST.
IF THE SHOE WERE ON THE
OTHER FOOT, WOULD YOU BE
TAKING THE SAME POSITION YOU
ARE TAKING TODAY?
I PASSED THAT TEST.
THERE ARE SOME OTHERS WHO
PASSED THAT TEST.
BUT TOO MANY BOTH ON THE
RIGHT AND ON THE LEFT DON'T
PASS THE TEST.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
WITH HILLARY CLINTON HAD
BEEN ELECTED A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE SUPPORTING ME AND
DEFINITING ME ON THE RIGHT
WOULD BE ATTACKING ME FOR
CRITICIZING THE PROSECUTION
OR THE IMPEACHMENT OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
WE NEED NEUTRAL PRINCIPLES.
WE NEED STANDARDS OF
CONSTITUTIONALITY THAT ARE
APOLITICAL AND I REFUSE TO
ALLOW PARTISAN POLITICS TO
PREEMPT MY VIEWS ON THE
CONSTITUTION WHICH HAVE
STAYED THE SAME FOR 50
YEARS.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
WHEN THE FBI BROKE INTO THE
G MAIL ACCOUNT OF THAT
CREEPY GOVERNOR ELIOT
SPITZER I DEFENDED THAT
SPITZER.
>> HE IS MY FRIEND.
HE WAS MY RESEARCH
ASSISTANT.
I LIKE ELLIOTT.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY WRONG